(gentle music)
- [Narrator] This is the Guthega Skink.
Small in size,
the Guthega Skink is
covered in camouflage skin
to blend in with the alpine rocks
they call home.
The Guthega Skink is native
to Victoria, Australia,
and can only be found in one area
known as the Bogong High Plains.
Because they are only
found in such a small area,
they are vulnerable to natural disasters,
such as bush fires,
but this isn't the only threat
facing the skinks.
Their habitat has also been affected
by the construction of ski resorts
and the grazing and
trampling from farm animals,
but their biggest threat
is climate change.
Warmer temperatures have
allowed new predators,
once kept at bay by the cold,
into their previously isolated habitat.
Zoos Victoria have been working
on a breeding program
to ensure the preservation of this species
and a rescue and recovery program
if there is an immediate threat
to the wild population.
This is the Guthega Skink.
(gentle music)
(gentle electronic music)